ممثله مغنيه اعلاميه كاتبه واكثر من ذلك
وجوه مختلفه جمعتها معا لتصبح من اشهر من
ظهر على شاشه البريطانيه خلال العقدين
الاخيرين كيف لا وهي قاضيه المواهب
البريطانيه اماندا هولدن التي تعطي اشاره
الاستمرار او التوقف للموهوبين الجدد فما
قصتها ولدت اماندا هولدن في شرق انجلترا
لكنها امضت طفولتها في بلده هامشيا
السياحيه ما جعلها دائما متحمسه لجماليات
الحياه فاحبت التمثيل مبكرا وشاركت في
المسرح اثناء دراستها الابتدائيه قبل ان
تحصل على اول دور لها في سلسله جرانادا
وتدرس الفن بمدرسه مونتفيو المسرحيه بين
عامي
1998 و2001
ظهرت اماندا في الكوميديا التلفزيونيه
ثم قامت بعده اعمال ناجحه سواء كانت
مسرحيه او عبر شاشات التلفاز والسينما
التي كان من ابرزها قيامها بدور ساره
رافانيان في ثلاث سلاسل من مسلسل وايلد
اتارت وبطوله مسرحيه
لجائزه لورانس اوليفي لكن التحول الاهم في
مسيرتها حدث في عام 2007 مع انضمامها
لبرنامج المواهب البريطاني
حيث حجزت مكانه لها كقاضيه في البرنامج
حتى اليوم كذلك انضمت في عام 2009
للبرنامج الصباحي عبر قناه
الامريكيه ونقلت الاحداث من بلدها كمراسله
ثم قدمت اماندا العديد من البرامج
التلفزيونيه لاي تي في مثل
لم يمنع عمل اماندا قاضيه ببرنامج المواهب
البريطاني من ان تظهر باعمال تمثيليه
امريكيه وبريطانيه
مثلدرز كذلك قامت باعمال مسرحيه متميزه
وحصلت على جائزه
ضمن فئه افضل ممثله في مسرحيه موسيقيه عن
دورها بمسرحيه شريك ذا ميوزكال كما اصدرت
البومها الغنائيه الاول سونغ فروم ماي
هارت في عام 2020 في عام 2013 نشرت اماندا
سيرتها الذاتيه تحت عنوان نوهولد باك
وكشفت انها في فتره من الفترات عملت في
متجر لبيع الاحذيه خلال عطله الاسبوع فيما
هي اليوم القاضيه البريطانيه ام اندا
هولدن التي يتابعها جمهور عريض عبر شاشات
التلفاز والاذاعه المحليه وكذلك من خلال
منصات التواصل الاجتماعي
وتتربع على ثروه تقدر بنحو 12 مليون دولار
[موسيقى]